on today's episode of yang speaks you've
got zack rowman and carly reilly we're
talking about how the media is covering
afghanistan we're talking about the
ultimate vaccine debate and we're
breaking down what the heck verifiable
credentials are and why they're going to
change the world tune into yang speaks
right now
[Music]
well carl i walked in the living room
yesterday and you were very upset about
afghanistan i think we're all upset but
you were
more emotional than all of us um
and i think it's it's not only what's
happening there but also kind of the way
things are being covered
um it trying to trigger a whole bunch of
emotions and thoughts in your brain
where's your head at on what's going on
in afghanistan
oh
yeah i think a lot of people were really
upset yesterday i know i got a text from
my my mom saying that she and my dad
were really upset so i know it's not
just me um
i think my
my first reaction was just
heartbreak and anger
on behalf of
the people who fought alongside us in
afghanistan
and our allies who were committed to
this vision we had
painted of a better future
and
who it feels like we have abandoned to
literally be slaughtered and
that
feeling like there was a betrayal there
and that we betrayed these people
it it it makes me really upset oh god
yeah there's um
you're not alone and i think the media
so we're not expert you have um
you actually have a deep passion for the
middle east but neither of us whatever
claim to be experts certainly in in this
space um
but i think we had a very very human
reactions that were shared by a lot of
people of just this is you know this is
the lefty and me feels like this is what
the united states sort of does is we
meddle in places that we don't fully
understand the lay of the land we don't
understand what's going on we don't
fully understand what we're getting
ourselves into and then
and then we leave
for reasons that i fully understand um
and
it's catastrophic for the people who are
there uh and
well we can't get democracy right in our
own country so trying to do it
in the middle of the world i mean we
have i believe
free and fair elections now you sound
like a uh i mean like we have tons of
problems here for us to like to us to
have the like
the gall to be like oh let us show you
how it's done seems a little bit of a
reach uh and to me it's it's more about
it's just very complicated to go into
foreign countries i mean so i i have a
good friend who
whose parents are diplomats and they
uh are diplomats in in eastern europe in
russia so they're
you know connected to the middle east
for various reasons um and she told me
that when we first sent troops into
afghanistan
we trained people in the wrong dialect
for the region we were sending them to
and it's like that's just epitomizes the
arrogance with which we approached this
situation
and we've basically seen that in 20
years we have not created a stable
country um so so
that my first reaction was just the the
my heart goes out to everyone there i
think it is i just can't imagine how
terrifying it is to have the taliban
come and storm your city or and
to know that you were somebody who
helped the americans that everyone knows
you were somebody who helps the
americans so it's just a matter of time
before you have your head chopped off
and you can't leave and i i mean i i
just think it is i think we should be
just outraged that we have put people in
this situation
which i am clearly i'm not i'm not gonna
cry i'm okay um and then i think it was
interesting because
you know i i am somebody who tends to
have a lot of empathy uh but have have
also found myself on the other side of
leftists who
[Music]
who kind of claim that they are the
they have a monopoly on empathy and
one of those situations is also the
middle east conflict israel-palestine
conflict which
came up again because i thought it was
striking how the media is covering
afghanistan as opposed to how some media
outlets covered the
israel-palestine situation recently um
so i tweeted this but there's a 501c3
foundation called the slow factory that
has a social media presence and does
blog posts etc and i want to share kind
of two two different posts that they
made so the first
was a post
recently i think it came out yesterday
today is tuesday we're recording this so
it was monday of this week um and it
said
quote it is not possible to condense
decades of conflict into a single
instagram post what's happening in
afghanistan is complex nuanced and
devastating we encourage our community
to take time to explore the list of
resources that we have shared
and then
somebody clever on twitter found
this post that slow factory had also
posted you know a month ago or a couple
months ago um
about israel and palestine
what is happening in palestine is not
complicated it's settler colonialism and
ethnic cleansing
so you have them saying you can't
actually that
decades-old conflicts can't be
summarized in a single instagram post
and then showing how they have suggested
that you can do exactly that when it
comes to israel-palestine
for israel palestine it's black and
white you're on one side of the other
but afghanistan it's complicated and i
think it's to me
the left is getting a healthy dose of
their
of medicine right now in the sense that
and i've been in this camp where we've
been calling for many of us on the left
and calling for the end of
the wars the end of the forever wars or
end of troops and wars in the middle
east for decades
and
we finally did it and it's literally
blowing up in our face in everyone's
face and um the reason is it's
complicated well that sounds like you're
suggesting that we shouldn't be pulling
out which i i'm not saying that you're
suggesting i'm not suggesting but my
point is that
yeah it's the right we need to get out
of there um
it's a shame that this is happening it's
this is complicated and um you can't
blame the body administration you can't
blame just the trump administration you
can't blame just bush and clinton like
this is 20 years
of
well you probably have to you can blame
everybody but the point like to blame
one is not fair it's 20 years of
um whether it's bad decisions or bad
intelligence or ineffective um
strategy who knows i'm not an expert but
the reality where we're at now
and anybody watching this should say
that this is heartbreaking and
complicated and
um
i wish there was more
it's complicated it's complicated
narrative really struck up my core
because if you remember and i don't
remember if we talked about it on here
we probably did but i was sort of
attacked on social media uh one woman in
particular christine sadelko who i
definitely know more about the israel
conflict then by the way
she like posted my picture on her
instagram feed etcetera etcetera you
know made fun of the way i looked i
don't care but the point of that is all
she did all of that i don't think i
talked about this because i said that
this conflict was complicated israel is
real palestine like literally me
suggesting it was complicated is what
provoked all this outrage from the left
and now when it comes to afghanistan
oh now we can always
okay
now i disagree you said that the left is
getting a heavy dose of
their own competence or something and i
i don't think they see it that way at
all i think oh they don't very much
think that
palestine israel palestine is not a
complicated situation which is just
mind-blowing um
it goes to something that i think we're
going to talk about a little bit later
which is that the strategy
over the years on the left seems to have
been seems to be stake out an
increasingly puritanical
black and white
position
and treat it like there's no nuance
and then attack anybody who doesn't
share that super puritanical view or
push that puritanical view further to
the left yeah
and it's why people like you and me who
are very liberal in
pretty much every policy area or
certainly i am right like
increasingly don't feel like we have a
home within the democratic party um your
home is on this podcast carl and i do
think that's a good segue to talking
about our vaccine debate because this is
another instance where
drawing a puritanical line
doesn't actually it somewhat helps but
doesn't always help accomplish your goal
but i do think and this is a good segue
it's like i think what's what's
happening is um and you're seeing this
everywhere this kind of lack of
institutional trust where we we don't
trust our military we don't trust our
schools we don't trust this and it's um
i want to segue into what we're all kind
of seeing both back here in the u.s is
this debate on vaccines and masks right
now with the delta variant ramping up we
are out here saying you the democrats
particularly and are saying the vaccine
is our savior get the vaccine 100 100
percent honestly get the vaccine and
that's true we should if you weigh it
out like do the digging like you we
should get a vaccine it is good i got
the vaccine you got the vaccine but it
is [ __ ]
to pretend that the vaccine is perfect
and it's inauthentic and it br it ruins
trust because the fact is there's a
point zero zero zero zero five percent
chance of some adverse side effects
which is actually better in some
instances
of
a whole bunch of other mandated vaccines
that we have for smallpox and measles
and going down the list but it's still a
small risk and i think we should all be
willing to take it but if we don't talk
about it you just lose your credibility
and that's right and then people who are
skeptical about taking the vaccine feel
like they're being treated like they're
crazy yes which on the one hand you're
like the risk is so small like you are
being crazy if you're if you're this
fearful about it it's because you're
being fed information that's
inaccurate but i also am not a believer
in demonizing people because they've
read and believed inaccurate information
like the the answer to that is not then
rolling your eyes and being like you're
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] right like the
answer to that is then like hey i hear
you you're concerned about this let me
talk to you like a human being who's not
a complete idiot because you're probably
not about why this is good
and
and that's the conversation that feels
like it's not being had as usual
here's a risk calculation on the vaccine
if you don't get it you're more likely
to die 1.7 of people die from covid um
and the vast majority of those people
who die from covet 99.5 of them are
unvaccinated so you're more likely to
die you increase your um you increase
your risk of getting covered you
increase the long-term effects and you
increase the ability to give it to
others and put strain on our system
if you get the vaccine you're less
likely to die
are less likely to hurt others but you
are exposed to a very small risk that
all vaccines have when there's vaccine
courts in the united states because our
vaccines while we pretend they're
perfect they are not now the chances are
point zero zero zero zero five percent
or
you know like the crazy numbers you're
looking at it's like a thousand out of
351 million which is ridiculously small
where you can get swelling of the heart
or small nerve damage or allergic
reaction on site these are real concerns
but they are tiny tiny tiny and in my
opinion so tiny it almost makes them not
real right and like that not in my
opinion i think factually considering
the cost benefits it makes a lot more
sense to take the risk of getting the
vaccine and the risk of getting covet
and plus you're helping
you're playing a part in helping others
in public health so if you cost benefit
this out as a public policy major when
school for this stuff the cost benefit
makes a lot of sense to get the vaccine
but i do understand where people are and
while i'm we are pro-vaccine
got my shot you've gotten your shot i
got my fauciouci all good two of them i
got my j j which i guess is the cheaper
one but whatever um
it makes sense to get the vaccine but i
totally understand that if people are
feeling like
you are selling me
a perfect utopian vaccine that is close
to perfect it's 99.99 effective whatever
the number is but it still has effective
now against delta variant this is where
like and this is well it is super
effective though because it's preventing
people from dying um sure well and when
but this is the problem if you sell a
perfect vaccine then when you have
things like this where the effectiveness
rate goes down you're just handing a
victory to the people who are skeptical
along because
you were selling a utopia that you can't
actually realistically deliver on right
the last thing i want to say is that
people are
very very particularly the conservatives
up in arms about a mandated vaccine
and i want to say that the government
has the right to mandate vaccines for
their own and businesses and schools
have the right to do this and we do this
we do this for chickenpox we do this for
measles we do this for polio we do it
for almost every major disease that
we've had a vaccine for
the government can do it for government
employees schools can do it for their
schools and businesses can do their
private business so for those freaking
out about overreach of the government
they are well within their right to
require it from public health standpoint
the same way they require pants the same
way they require tetanus shots this is
in that lane and you're going to see
that as this vaccine gets through the
fda it gets approved i think that it's
important to clarify because when people
hear government mandated right that's
all the republican spidey senses like
start tingling
and
does this mean that if you don't have
the vaccine if i don't have the vaccine
and i'm just walking around outside i'm
gonna be cuffed and put in jail
no
okay and i think that's the piece
that may actually be important to
clarify my understanding is a government
mandate means if you're going to be in a
government building around government
other government officials right like
france bans religious symbolism in
government buildings they say you can't
wear a burqa or uh you know yamaka or
something in a in a government building
that's a government ban on religious
symbols right but that doesn't mean that
you know they've banned it for everybody
and it's a big distinction like you
cannot get the vaccine all you want you
just can't participate get the vaccine
if you're going to work in a government
building if you're going to be around
other these other governments if you're
going to be in school if you're gonna
and like every business has the right to
say at least right now legally and legal
precedence saying that you have the
rights you're saying if you're chipotle
if you're not vaccinating you're not not
allowed to come in here and by the way
if as a business i have the right to say
i won't bake you a cake because you're
gay it's also valid to say i won't let
you work here if you don't have a
vaccine you're going to kill my staff
right because i'm worried about covid
you could say that so
that is what we're talking about where
it gets dicey where i'm i'm hesitant is
how far that reach goes whereas one
thing like private business is right but
if government if the federal government
starts saying you can't cross state
lines if you haven't gotten the vaccine
and i have empathy truly like this is
what because i think most of our
listeners are pro-vaccine and
i've probably gotten it
and
and because democrats claim they're the
party of empathy but i think they
sometimes have real blind spots to it
i had empathy for the people who are
living in call it red states or southern
states
who for a variety of reasons all they're
being fed is
propaganda or or lies about what this
vaccine is and they're stuck in that
bubble and in that loop on their social
media feeds on their
podcast like everywhere they turn that's
all they're getting right and then they
hear the government saying you can't
leave your state unless you're
vaccinated and they truly believe that
the vaccine is going to cause all sorts
of horrible things because that's all
they're that's all they've been
consuming like i actually have empathy
for that sense of i've now been trapped
grabbed my gun and stormed the
government i don't agree with any of it
at all but i think it's really important
to put yourself in the mind of people
who
are living in that universe i think
right the fact we don't do that enough
and that's how we end up just like
talking past each other all the time
what's heartbreaking is that we have a
literally objectively a miracle vaccine
it is a wonderful thing it is saving
millions of lives and our country and
our world as we know it
and we've politicized it where we can't
have rational conversations about it and
there are people that are
not getting it
and theoretically hurting others
because of political views and that's
where we are as a country and it's very
very it's heartbreaking similar
afghanistan it's heartbreaking um
okay let's talk about verifiable
credentials
and talk we got sebastian on who's
pretty awesome i've learned a ton about
verifiable credentials and it's a way to
somewhat establish a different type of
trust
when the world around us is burning you
met sebastian in person right yeah i met
sebastian a couple weeks ago in miami
the the trip that keeps on giving i went
to miami for miami hack week met a bunch
of badass developers coders
entrepreneurs working on really cool
projects sebastian was one of them
i've been a fan of verifiable
credentials for for a little while now
uh as in like a few months but that's
actually a long time in blockchain world
because most of this [ __ ] is like
um
so if you're talking about how to verify
someone's got a vaccine without a big
brother situation verifiable credentials
on the blockchain are your solution am i
right sure
i mean it's a it's a way to verify that
you've gotten the vaccine without the
government or a state government for
example having to store vaccine records
of everybody
but they're not like yeah but they're
not they're not going to keep and store
all of that so if all of this this all
might be gibberish to you why don't we
just get into the episode so people can
understand introducing power back into
individual hands oh sebastian mellon
co-founder ceo of cerebrum
you'll learn more about it right now
[Music]
all right i am so excited to have
sebastian mellon here he is the ceo and
co-founder of cerebrum sebastian you and
i had the pleasure of meeting in miami
for miami hack
and i thought what you're doing was
super interesting i thought you were
super fun and impressive and so we
wanted to bring you on to talk a little
bit more about what you're up to and
what cerebrum is up to uh so maybe we
start there do you want to tell us yeah
what the hell are you doing what is
cerebrum and what do you do
so uh i'm the co-founder and ceo of
cerebrum you can visit us at
cerebrum.com also linked up here if
you're on video
and what we do at cerebrum is we verify
all kinds of data now that means
everything from background checks to
covet tests to drug tests
and pretty much everything in between
there's a big problem uh in the modern
world which is that a lot of the
information that we interact with is in
what i call credential format and that
means that it has three basic attributes
it has an issuer it has a recipient and
it usually has a set of claims about
that recipient or about some something
associated with that recipient so for
example
a driver's license is a credential right
because it's issued by usually a state
dmv the recipient is an individual and
it has a set of claims like your address
date of birth
your ability to drive so on and so forth
and you're an organ donor or whatever
yeah exactly check box you've got an
organ donor folks check that box
no right there right there with you um
and so all those sets of claims which
are really important right like being an
organ donor or not are affixed to this
credential now the thing is for
important credentials like driver's
licenses we have a lot of ways to verify
them right we have holograms we have
other anti-forgery devices and generally
speaking you know unless maybe you want
to get into a bar
and you're going to college and you're
not 21 yet
there's no real need to sort of forge
these credentials uh for for sort of
official purposes right if you tried
you'd get caught maybe you can get by
the bouncer but you can't get by sort of
the state government um
but
that credential is expensive to create
right it costs a lot of money to print
that driver's license to authenticate it
and there are there's a lot of work that
goes into creating that card
now a lot of other documents which are
also equally important
don't have that kind of verification
built into them because they're either
digital documents that aren't
represented in sort of physical format
like a driver's license is
or there's something like a paper
document right and one of the examples
which i think can translate what we do
at cerebrum best is what we're doing at
lax right now so we recently launched
about six weeks ago a program at lax
where we started verifying all of their
coveted test results and as the airport
right for those who don't la or travel
often right that's uh
los angeles international airport um
and so at los angeles airport lax
there's a lot of covet testing going on
there's a lot of people traveling
overseas to locations where kova tests
are still required
the biggest problem is that these covet
tests up until now and actually still in
most locations are issued without really
any way to verify them except for
calling the laboratory right so the
process traditionally is the person in
you know the airport at in france or in
australia will call the laboratory and
we'll say hey we have a suspicious
looking test or we want to verify that
this test is legitimate could you check
this number and confirm that this
information actually matches what's in
what's in your laboratory system that
you actually issued this test
uh and that's a laborious process it
takes a lot of time you're missing your
flight at that point exactly you're
missing your flight you're not getting
to your end destination
not at all
right not at all and you know the worst
thing is that sometimes the lab isn't
open right if you're in france and all
you know it's whatever midnight for the
lab there's no way to verify um
and and it's just a it's just a messy
process right like there's no
there no easy way to verify that kind of
data right now well i think the the fun
example that i'd give is you so you and
i were just in miami hack week
not to blow up your spot but you showed
up with a intentionally falsified
uh vaccination card to make your point
that it is very easy to falsify these
vaccination cards right now because it's
a piece of paper that
you know you can write on and and the
people checking these things are like
giving it a glance being like yeah sure
looks legit i don't know and like we all
move along with our day yeah so this is
what you you at cerebrum you're not
singularly trying to solve a like false
document problem but you are operating
in the healthcare space and trying to
make smoother the process of
verifying health records sharing health
you know sharing health information etc
is that yeah that's actually right
that's essentially right um we do a lot
of work actually in a lot of sort of
different sectors through a large
background check company which is a
close partner of ours that does about
six to seven million background checks
annually so they have a lot of people
and a lot of important data that they're
verifying and what we're able to do most
simply like in this covet testing
scenario what we're working on
vaccination cards what we're working on
with a set of other documents is a fix a
sort of qr code
to the document that is scannable and
that scannable qr code pulls up a page
which shows that cryptographic trail
which verifies whether or not that
document and the contents within it are
legitimate and we can get into in a
moment sort of how that works but i'll
i'll give you a little bit more of a
background on
sort of how i came to cerebrum and and
what we do
more generally with the different
industries that we touch because
we don't just work in healthcare we also
work on the compliance side of things
like youth sports um where
uh you know sexual uh offenders sex
offenders assault um is unfortunately a
very big problem there are predators out
there right and there's all sorts of
people who worm their way for example
into youth sports leagues and the way
that they get into these youth sports
leagues is maybe they make friends with
an administrator or they don't get
background checked yeah it's really dark
right
and um
the
the the process that we're able to
enforce there is through another
application of this sort of core
technology that we use which is called
verifiable credential technology
and we'll get into sort of how that
works yeah
how does this how does this functioning
work i know you're yeah you're
fundamentally on the blockchain but that
means so many different things to so
many people now especially slower people
like me definitely
how does it work yeah so i think if we
start from the basics it might help here
so
basically what a blockchain is
is it's a big
series of transactions it's basically
just like a long ledger right
but it has
a very special attribute which is that
to write data to this ledger you need to
write it from what's called a public
private key pair
and the way that you can think about a
public private key pair is sort of like
a po box so if you have a po box
everyone knows your address right
everyone can send mail to that address
or in the case of a blockchain send
currency to that address
but only you have the key to that box
which allows you to unlock it and send
information from that address or get the
information sort of encoded within that
address which might be currency or other
kinds of information
and
with the blockchain you can actually
also prove that you sent information
from a certain po box and what that
means is that we can give everybody a po
box including let's say issuers of
important information and recipients of
important information and sort of say
verifiably hey
this organization at this address issued
this letter or this information or this
document and actually sent that to the
po box of a certain recipient and that
means that i can then go to anybody else
and say hey here's this sort of
certified mail if you will coming from
whatever it may be acme inc uh the state
dmv
and here's the proof the cryptographic
proof that i haven't tampered with it
since it was sent to me by that issuing
organization right and in practice what
that means is that we can take all sorts
of information like let's say a
background check which says that you're
not a sex offender you don't have any
national criminal records so on and so
forth
package that into this sort of
cryptographically verifiable package
which really just means that i can't
tamper with it and then i can share that
package with anybody else and they can
verify that that information is
legitimate and that i haven't tampered
with it in that process so essentially
sebastian is ruining underage
drinking
for forever yeah screw you
yeah so no i mean i joke but truthfully
we are
fake id that said i was 25 that had
holographic keys on it would have worked
in a world where sebastian doesn't exist
thanks a lot what did work in a world
where sebastian didn't exist well and
it's funny you had a vermont id a fake
id i had a connecticut fake id you lived
in connecticut i lived in vermont anyhow
well my my point was a bigger question
is
so this sounds like all right we all
have a
like your birth certificate or social
security card for some of those and
there's there was a world
in order to get your passport you needed
it in order to get your driver's license
sometimes needed
and
i agree well look one you're solving a
couple problems one if it's digital it's
a lot harder to lose i imagine um right
because it's theoretically in the cloud
or somewhere um for sure and two
particularly social security cards um
they're a little
probably
probably easier to fake in many ways or
there's always people making copies and
things like that um and this would be
100 verified every time at no additional
cost to both the producer and
the
consumer is that
that that's a that's simple for me to
understand yeah it's it's a fair way of
looking at it and it's and it's a sort
of a good breakdown of where this
technology can be applied now the way
that we see it at cerebrum is that this
is really space age technology that
allows anybody to verify any kind of
information
and who it came from and it also has
additional attributes uh like the fact
that you can do something called zero
knowledge proofs and that's an example
of where you might have a driver's
license and you want to go to a bar and
you don't want to show you know the
bouncer or the bartender
your address your name your date of
birth any of this sort of sensitive
information about yourself which you
reveal anytime you give someone your id
and so you can generate a proof
which proves that you're over 21 without
revealing any other information you
don't have to show your birthday you
just need to draw a verified credential
that validates that you're over 21.
you've got it and so this is this
concept of like self-sovereign identity
is that right like exactly i as the
individual and then total control of
what i share yeah i i think what's
interesting
is i know you don't know it's you don't
exclusively work in healthcare but
sure you showed me a really cool example
of how a hospital for example could
issue a verified credential using your
platform to an individual
and i i found that so interesting
because i read a story previously about
i think there was a famous actress
somewhere in europe
who had been admitted to a hospital and
it ended up being found out that her
hospital records were viewed like over
350 times or some many number of times
by hospital workers and administrators
who had access to their system who were
able to go in and because she was a
celebrity wanted to go see her health
records yeah something like this is a
really powerful way to to combat against
that is that oh yeah right a hundred
percent and actually since you bring
that up all you know the thing that we
built at miami hack week was this
vaccination um
sort of verification system and the way
that that worked is you could come in
enter your information it would enter
create sort of a demo vaccine card for
you issued by the miami hackweek health
center and actually if you'd like you
can go to miamihackweek.org
and create one yourself right now it's
live there and then you can try and
verify it and validate it that qr code
will link to a web page
but you bring up a really important part
of this system which is that
the core concept of self-sovereign
identity is based on consent basically
if i want to share you some attribute
about myself or prove something about
myself i now have the ability to do that
i can prove that i have a certain
background check i can prove that i have
a certain vaccination i can prove that
i've had a cova test or anything else
like that i can prove that my certain
medical records or prescriptions were
issued by the correct parties but if i
don't want to share it i'm not compelled
to and the choice to share that is
always up to me
and that's one of the things that i also
find important you know not only in sort
of medical records healthcare but more
specifically in the place we're at right
now with vaccination records and
vaccination verification because there's
a lot of concern and i actually think
rightly so about having these
centralized databases of who has which
status and who's been vaccinated how yes
you know i think the right way to
approach it is say look if you want to
verify that you've been vaccinated let's
give you the tools so that you can do
that right let's not sort of create this
surveillance state where everybody's
tracked in a central database let's give
you the tools so you can say i've been
vaccinated and if you want to go to an
event with other vaccinated people you
can be sure that everybody there has
been vaccinated as well right and if you
want to um
you know not reveal your vaccination
status and not be admitted to such an
event that's that's your right right you
don't have to be tracked we don't have
to have a surveillance state to keep
everybody safe and i think that's one of
the most important sort of concepts of
self-sovereign identity and really
verifiable credentials more generally
you know what are the restrictions on
doing this so this all sounds like a
dream scenario in theory where i have
all my info
it's in my crypto wallet or it's in my
some form of
platform right and i can pick and choose
what i need to share and one of the
things i hate where it's um
for example if you're getting an
apartment you're gonna rent something
right and they need to do a credit check
on you right i all they need my social
security number to go to equifax or
wherever they want to go check my credit
right but in the process of that i give
my social security number to a broker
then to a landlord then to building
management then to equifax and back down
the chain those people don't need my
social security number um
so but my question is
in order for this to work right let's
say you build one thing but then
let's say equifax builds another type of
blockchain
verifiable ident like you know
like verifiable credentials
mcdonald's has one to make sure this and
then everybody's got their own different
chains right can they like is there um
a way for them to work seamlessly is how
the blockchain works or does like does
everybody build their own things there's
a middleman
to connect them all
yeah it's that's that's a really uh
cogent question and i think it's an
important one to ask right now this
whole space is very nascent right and a
lot of what's going on is
experimentation making sure that things
work and trying to find sort of initial
use cases because right the technology
is brilliant but if you can't really
apply it
exactly in real life it's complicated
and the thing is a lot of legacy
industries it's actually against their
business models to integrate with
self-sovereign identities
exactly so they're in some way they're
actually disincentivized to adopt this
technology which is
not great right it's a downside um and
it's also a risk for for companies that
are trying to build in this space now i
love the example that you brought up
actually about credit checks because in
the work that we do uh with this
background check company a lot of what
we're working on is the concept of data
minimization right so to tie back to
that youth sports example if i want to
go on a on a field as a volunteer or a
parent coach and show my status that i
have a certain registration card that
i'm not a sex offender so on and so
forth all i have to prove is a
credential that shows
i'm i'm qualified right and that
qualification means all of these other
things but i don't have to share that
background check with my local
administrator which contains my social
security number address date of birth
all that information right same thing if
you're going to get a credit check now
you can prove look my credit score was
authenticated by this background check
company which is why we have this
partnership and it's so useful to us you
can share that with anybody else and no
one else needs to know what your social
security number is or your other
information to verify that data right
and
uh correct me if i'm wrong sebastian but
a lot of people who are building and
working in this space and i would
imagine cerebrum as well are building
using open standards so this would get
to zach's point about
yeah can these be transferred and the
beauty of i think this industry is that
people have a real they want to make
this new future a reality right yeah so
they're they're working within the
within the framework of open standards
which sebastian you can probably speak
to better than i can but
essentially zach what that enables is
that yes if all these different
companies have their own kind of
credential
they actually work seamlessly within
each other and within the systems that
are being built right you've got it yeah
so facebook for example it's i think is
a good example of like widespread
mainstream adoption where they start
with their college kids who are tech
savvy but they mentioned they actually
get to my parents who think the college
kids are doing something cool and now
it's right grandma and grandpa um right
right right we still don't really
understand it but that's fine but um
they're
my experience with with the blockchain
and buying i bought it i bought ethereum
and i have a little bit of bitcoin and
carly made me buy a stoner cat um okay
that's my that's my crypto experience i
wanted him to buy a friend which is
really going which we should have
i did but yeah carly's killing on that
anyway okay i hear you but it was it was
complicated yes there are and every time
i think i understand there's a new term
or a new like i didn't know anything
about gas prices and now i have right
which is like how the cost of
buying or selling crypto um essentially
right so my question is
in your opinion
what you're doing is it's
just going to be cool it's is it like
tick tock in the sense that grandma
grandpa are never going to do it but
this is like eventually going to become
the new norm because young people
understand this and we'll learn it and
grow up with it yeah or is there a world
where this becomes mainstream because my
fear is
if it's tick-tock
40 years from now we're still using
social security cards um
and that's funny because my my main
question was going to be how long until
this is mainstream because i have
pre-support like i'm already all the
crypto people like everybody's going to
do this right right right right i don't
really agree um i want no
and i mean zach i think you make a
really
important point which is that a lot of
this technology is inaccessible and
that's actually a big problem i mean if
everybody who
has access to self-sovereign identity is
someone who's already privileged if you
will that's not really doing
that much good right and if that means
that one percent of people get to hide
their social security numbers and
everybody else gets relegated to these
legacy systems that they don't
understand and you know have to be sort
of forced into that's also no good one
of the biggest focuses that we have at
cerebrum is finding real world
applications of this technology that are
also actually easier to use than legacy
systems and that means that you don't
have to understand gas or you don't have
to understand public private key pairs
or blockchain transactions or even what
a
shot 256 hash is right all you have to
understand is this green check mark
shows up and if i want to go into the
technology if i'm a tech savvy person or
if i really want to verify this data i
can follow that trail right but if i
don't i don't have to and so one of the
examples is for this demo that we built
at this miami hack week
is a project around sort of verifying
those vaccinations right and we were
actually able to put that onto these nfc
cards so if you tap your phone with an
nfc card it'll pull up a validator link
if you scan a qr code with your phone
it'll pull up a validator link and then
our validator system will show you this
credentials legitimate here's the
cryptographic proof if you want to
verify it if you don't here's the rest
of the data and the really nice thing
about that actually in contrast also to
things like the excelsior pass which you
may be familiar with if you're in new
york in new york city yeah
is that it
it's it's accessible to people who
don't have a smartphone right and a
large portion a surprisingly large
portion of the us population doesn't
have access to the internet or the smart
or smartphones and with this we can
issue them a little card and anyone who
wants to verify it just needs a
smartphone they don't need an app they
don't even need to know how to use an
app they just tap it on the back of
their phone same with a qr code and
that's for example one application where
i think this technology is actually
really useful the cryptographic
verification is done on the verifier
side and all that the holder of that
credential needs to have is a card or a
qr code and that can be on paper they
can hold that in their wallet they don't
need to understand any of these complex
concepts but they can still benefit from
that you know technology and sort of the
leverage that that cryptographic
verification gives them we've now
politicized it's so funny when coveting
started we're all like oh god we need a
vaccine let's get this over with and now
the vaccine's most political thing out
there i don't think to the average
person but at least in the media it
feels like everybody's got a really
strong opinion yeah yeah and
you know carl and i have talked um and i
know we we're both kind of laying in the
middle it's like look you want to get
vaccinated you should it's better for
society there's a lot of science like
most of the signs and most medical
communities saying get vaccinated for
sure but there's also i believe
particularly those who lean more
conservative this fear
of an authoritarian government which is
like you can't come into new york city
or can't travel in between state borders
if you're not vaccinated um oh yeah
and so there's that piece and the
concept or like excelsior or the vaccine
barcode or license whatever it is where
you're feeling like the government has
this
crazy checker
or not check box of um database of of
human beings yeah um which feels
on the extreme end people are saying
it's like the holocaust i would say
that's too extreme but it does feel a
little authoritarian and big brother-y
um yeah you had mentioned how this could
be a happy medium but thoughts on you
know your thoughts there and um
is it even possible to
to thread the needle here yeah you know
it's it is a big topic and i think it's
a really important conversation to have
i think that that with something like
this there are no easy answers
um just because there's so much
complexity swirling around on the
medical community on the civil rights
side on the equality of access side
everything is is sort of uncertain but
it is important i think that that we
take steps to safeguard people and also
you know keep people's civil rights
intact and so
the way i see it is sort of twofold one
side of things is a lot of the people
who have problems with this um sort of
vaccination push or are hesitant to get
the vaccine i think are actually
hesitant mostly because they don't have
the same level of privilege or access
that a lot of people who do get the
vaccine do who have easy ways to make
vaccine appointments easy ways to
download these apps live in circles
where it's quite common to get the
vaccine everybody's open to it
and and it may also feel you know if you
don't have a smartphone or if you uh
don't have internet access and you're
hearing about new york city implementing
this uh forced vaccination pass that you
need a smartphone to use you know that's
that's terrifying right how am i i'm not
going to be able to participate in
society and i think that offering the
ability to use like technologies like
nfc cards or qr codes where you don't
need to have a smartphone is a is a step
forward now on the mandate side
i also don't think mandates i'm
personally not in favor of mandates and
the reason for that is that i think that
if you want to be around people who are
vaccinated we should build the tools so
that that can happen if you want to have
a community if you want to have events
where you can verify that data let's
build those tools and that's a lot of
what we're working on
at cerebrum and
one last piece of that actually is that
sort of centralized database concept the
ultimate goal of self-sovereign identity
is really that you don't have those
centralized databases and that means
that the vaccine site itself issues that
credential and then there's no real
centralized database of who has which
vaccinations there's just this
cryptographic proof that you actually
got a vaccination if you want to share
it and it's not something that's stored
in this sort of big brother type
surveillance state centralized database
as for sort of the political side and
how mandates will work and how events
and private venues versus government
institutions can require that i think
that's a really complex interplay and
i'd say you know i'm not an expert in
that field so i'm probably not qualified
to comment more deeply on it i hope
that's a sufficient answer yeah that's
fair all right cool the the last thing
i'd add which is up here if you're on
video but um if not is i'll put up a
list of resources at cerebrum.com
yang speaks about self-sovereign
identity verifiable credentials how
those different pieces interact
and sort of how we see that working and
a little bit more about what we're doing
at cerebrum including like a press
release about our lax project and a link
to that vaccine card demo system and
that's c-e-r-e-b-r-u-m.com
y-a-n-g speaks yangspeaks cerebrum.com
yang speaks awesome iraq and you are you
you are a yang donor so i am two times
for both campaigns a two-time yang donor
near and dear in our hearts thanks man
here's some time we'll win one for you
i'm i'm all there with you that's our
show today tune in every thursday zach
graham and carly reilly here on
yankspeaks we'll see you guys next
thursday
[Music]
[Music]
you